[Musique]
bonjour Stéphane Simon je vous en prie
installez-vous merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous être journaliste auteur
de ce livre les derniers jours de Samuel
paatti enquête sur une tragédie qui
aurait dû être évitée c'est chez plomb
et ça raconte évidemment c'est 11 jours
avant la mort de Samuel Patti on va
longuement parler lundi ça fera 3 ans
Samuel Patti a été assassiné est-ce
qu'on est au-delà d'un acte terroriste
on est sur un scandale d'État on est en
fait c'est vraiment une affaire qui qui
dépasse le cadre d'un fait divers euh
c'est beaucoup plus que ça c'est une
c'est c'est une atteinte évidemment à la
République puisque ce ce crime va va
s'attaquer à l'un d'entre l'un de ses
serviteurs un professeur euh c'est une
c'est c'est un acte euh je dirais aussi
euh de guerre de l'islamisme politique
contre la République française et
évidemment c'est un c'est au-delà de
cela euh puisque on voit qu'il y a il y
a il y a vous savez des des criminels
qui sont l'assassin ses complices mais
il y a aussi à faire l'examen de toutes
les responsabilités qui ont conduit
beaucoup de gens à ne pas agir euh parce
que évidemment dans ce type d'affaire il
y a ceux qui agissent et qui se rendent
coupables de crime d'assassinat en en
l'occurrence on se souvient de de
l'horreur de cette décapitation mais il
y a aussi tous ceux qui n'ont pas permis
de de de d'empêcher ce ce drame et c'est
ce que raconte votre livre c'est aussi
le renoncement de notre société dans la
lutte contre l'islamisme c'est-à-dire
c'est c'est c'est c'est à la fois du du
lychage de certains islamistes on le
montre dans dans ce livre c'est aussi du
lâchage de certains de ses collègues pas
tous moi je ne stigmatise pas l'ensemble
des professeurs mais il se trouve que
certains d'entre eux n'ont pas eu une
attitude à la hauteur des des des
circonstances euh certains ont se sont
comportés convenablement mais beaucoup
ont regardé le leurs chaussures durant
cette cette période puis certains même
ont ont contribué à salir Samuel Patti
donc évidemment c'est aussi le le procès
de ses
lâcheté de de ses collègues de la
hiérarchie qui n'a pas mise en œuvre les
ce qui aurait dû être misise en œuvre
que l'on dénonce dans ce livre on va en
parler évidemment dans le détail elle a
été à faire cette enquête pour vous elle
a été longue elle a été dure elle prend
le pas aussi de l'enquête du du parquet
antiterroriste et car nous avons eu
accès à un certain nombre de documents
on a pu consulter beaucoup de documents
de l'instruction et évidemment c'est une
c'est une enquête qui n'est pas simple
parce que d'une part il y a des gens qui
n'ont pas envie de parler de cela il y
en a enfin je dirais que l'essentiel
même des acteurs de ce drame n'ont pas
envie qu'on en parle plus que cela
puisque il y a des des irresponsabilités
voire des fautes qui ont été commises et
évidemment c'est jamais très agréable
quand et puis du côté du collège du bois
d'ulme à à Conflant saint-honorine bah
il y a destas de gens qui n'ont plus
tellement envie qui ont envie soit de
tourner la page parce que c'est quand
même une une période très douloureuse à
essayer d'évacuer puis il y a un certain
nombre de collègues qui n'ont pas non
plus envie qu'on leur rappelle qu'ils
ont pas tous été exemplaires donc
évidemment C c'est c'est c'est pas
facile de faire des enquêtes dans ces
conditions et puis après il y a
l'enquête du voisinage et c'était c'est
c'est vrai que Samuel pati éit un un un
homme exemplaire mais tisux c'était un
un homme discret cé un professeur tout à
sa tâche et qui n'était pas un un
exubérant donc si vous voulez ça fait
que l'enquête a été difficile à mener
mais on l'a voulu la le plus précise
possible c'est une une enquête clinique
qui ne porte pas de jugement qui est là
vraiment comme comme comme une autopsie
euh il a été assassiné autoption les
faits qui ont rendu possible cette cet
assassin effectivement votre livre c'est
un récit très factuel une enquête
minutieuse un récit glaçant de ces 11
jours qui ont précédé la mort de Samuel
pati ça commence le lundi 5 octobre 2020
avec ce cours d'éducation civique sur
les libertés fondamentales au cours
duquel il monte les caricatures de ma
oui et comme il le refera le lendemain
mais il fait tout cela je dirais dans un
cadre parfaitement parfaitement autorisé
et il n'y a rien de très original dans
son cours c'est un cours que la plupart
des professeurs d'histoiregéographie
font il le fait à sa manière parce que
c'est un professeur qui a à cœur d'être
très pédagogue et de rendre ses cours
vivants et c'est en cela qu'il est allé
chercher les caricature ce cours est
consacré à la liberté d'expression mais
dans ce cours il y a une partie
consacrée à à Charlie être ou ne pas
être Charlie colonne de gauche être
Charlie qu'est-ce que ça veut dire voilà
ne pas être Charlie pourquoi ça peut
blesser aussi les démarches les
caricature de Charlier il le fait comme
je dirais vraiment de façon très
équilibrée très balancée et euh et les
caricatures de momé c'est une toute
petite partie du cours ça ne dure que
quelques secondes ça dure 2 minutes à
tout le plus et pendant ces 2 minutes il
a en plus la je dirais le comment
dirais-je le le la sensibilité de se
dire que si certains veulent s'absenter
pour ne pas regarder ces caricatures ils
peuvent le faire le lundi ils pourront
le faire il y a une assistante de vie
scolaire qui qui va accompagner CIN cinq
élèves à l'extérieur du cours le
lendemain le mardi il y a pas
d'assistante de vie scolaire donc en
fait il va demander au au aux élèves
simplement de tourner la tête dans
l'ensemble de son cours il croit bien
faire il faut quand même oui bien sûr il
croyait bien faire en faisant cela mais
il faut quand même rappeler que tout ça
ce n'est pas le problème en vérité le
problème c'est aussi un mensonge c'est
le mensonge d'une gamine qui était qui
est une GAM on y vient parce que vous
vous le racontez le cours se passe bien
cour y a pas de problème avec les élèves
vous racontez aussi le témoignage des
ashh qui étit avec les cinq élèves
justement dehors et qui disent qu'elles
n'ont rien entendu pendant le cours mais
derrière ça commence par une plainte
d'une mère d'élève qui appelle la
principale et ensuite le mensonge de cet
élève et là c'est le début de
l'engrenage bien sûr en fait cette si
vous voulez les les élèves n'ont pas été
heurtés il n'y a pas eu d'incident
pendant les cours de Samuel Patti il se
trouve que parmi les élèves de Samuel
Patti il y a une certaine Z et cette Z
elle va faire des problèmes à la maison
elle s'est fait virer par la direction
du collège qui n'est pas ce n'est qui
n'a rien à voir avec Samuel paatti c'est
pas Samuel Patti qui décide de son
exclusion il se trouve qu'elle a eu déjà
11 inscriptions en l'espace d'un mois 11
inscriptions sur son cahier de
correspondance dont elle déchire
soigneusement les pages pour pas que ses
parents voi et vous dites c'est c'est le
cauchemar des prof c'est le cauchemar
des profs c'est quelqu'un qui se bat à
la cantine avec la nourriture c'est
quelqu'un qui porte qui ne veut pas
porter le masque pendant la période de
dont on se souvient des précautions
sanitaires qu'il y a pendant le covid
donc c'est quelqu'un qui est un c'est
c'est une élève problématique et en
rentrant chez elle plutôt que de dire
qu'elle s'est fait virer pour
indiscipline elle va dire qu'elle s'est
fait virer parce que elle a refuser de
regarder les caricatures de de Charlie
durant le cours de Samuel Patti et là
c'est la colère du père de famille c'est
la colère de tous ceux qui entourent le
père de famille et et et qui vont dès le
lendemain aller se plaindre à la
principale et demander immédiatement
l'exclusion de ce voyou de Samuel paatti
voilà où on en est et évidemment là
commenc les problèmes parce que il
aurait fallu maintenir je pense cette
cette famille un peu à distance lui
inculquer les principes d'autorité qui
font que on ne va pas claquer la porte
de la principale comme ça on prend
rendez-vous on commence par prendre
rendez-vous et moi je suis un fils de
prof petit fils de prof arrière
Petitfils de prof et je me souviens qu'à
la maison mes parents avaient soin de
dire que les que que quand les parents
pouvaient poser problèm les parents
d'élèves et bien on faisait attention à
ce que il y a un peu d'autorité qu'il
qu'il qu'il qu'il soit comment dire
dirais-je respectueux de cette autorité
et là on a une famille qui ne respecte
pas l'autorité qui ne respecte pas la
principale qui demande l'exclusion d'un
professeur enfin on est dans un mais la
principale les reçoit mais la principale
les reçoit avec beaucoup d'égard pour
entendre en plus puisqu'ils ont attendu
une demi-heure ce qui est quand même pas
grand-chose pour quelqu'un qui n'a pas
pris rendez-vous pour s'entendre dire si
nous avions été Juifs nous aurions été
reçus immédiatement nous sommes donc
déjà victimes d'islamophobie et c'est
bien tout le drame c'est des gens qui
utilisent le prétexte de d'un
hypothétique et mensonger Islam
mensongère islamophobie pour se placer
en victime et pour réclamer et pour dire
que ce ce voyou de Samuel paatti et
cetera et cetera et et et et juste parce
qu'il y a quelque chose qui est quand
même important quand elle les reçoit ce
qu'on apprendra après c'est que l'élève
en question Zain n'a pas assisté au
cours de Samuel pay elle avait séché
toute cette journée là sauf que la Prin
principal ne le sait pas c'est déjà un
premier dysfonctionnement voilà et et si
vous voulez ce qui est malaisant à
travers notre enquête c'est qu'on se on
se rend compte que à peine Samuel paaty
est pointé du doigt par ces par ces
islamistes que on lui demande de
présenter des excuses et dès la première
plainte de la mère d'élève avant même
d'avoir reçu sonè et et au prétexte que
présenter des excuses c'est pas très
engageant allez monsieur paatti bon on a
compris présentez vos excuses ça va
apaiser tout le monde ce qui est
absolument sidérant si vous voulez on n'
pas à s'excuser de choses que l'on de de
de problèmes que l'on n'a pas généré
donc euh on demande plus rapidement à ce
professeur de s'excuser plutôt que de
lui demander sa version des faits ce qui
est absolument incroyable et et
d'ailleurs la principale va attendre le
jeudi soir pour être pour avoir bien
compris enfin que cet élève n'était pas
en cours et donc qu'elle rapporte des
propos qui sont erronés et et et tout ça
évidemment ne participe pas à à un
climat serein on se met dans la tête de
ce professeur qui est désavoué avant
même d'avoir pu s'expliquer dites et
vous le dites il y a le le le manque de
soutien de la hiérarchie
puisqueeffectivement la principale lui
demande de s'excuser et et vous racontez
aussi quelques jours après pardon qu'une
de ses collègues professeur d'histoire
géo euh dit en salle des profs Samuel il
a merdé Samuel a merdé c'est-à-dire
qu'il va se faire accueillir euh plus
tard par par deux de ses collègues de
façon extrêmement violente c'estes ses
collègues qui devrait serrer les coutes
dans lesépreuves quand un quand le
collège est menacé la moindre des choses
dans enfin dans une boîte privée vous
savez on dit il faut avoir l'esprit
corporate bah là il y a pas d'esprit
corporate croyez-moi il se trouve elle
veut même écrire à l'Inspection
d'Académie pour se désolidariser deel P
exactement plutôt que d'accueillir avec
bienveillance un professeur dans la
tourmente et bien c'est le contraire on
le pointe du doigt on dit qu'il a merdé
et et on menace d'écrire à l'Inspection
Académique pour dénoncer son collègue
c'est pas reluisant si vous voulez quand
on va parler là alors évidemment ce
n'est pas l'attitude de tous ses
collègues attention je je je fais bien
le disting parlez d'un professeur
particulièrement qu'il soutient que oui
et je pense d'ailleurs que ce professeur
aura quelques problèmes quand le procès
va démarrer où on va entendre aussi ce
que les élèves ont dit de l'attitude de
ce collègue de Samuel Patti au début on
a un peu l'impression que Samuel Patti
il ne comprend pas la polémique il ne
voit pas en tout cas venir l'ampleur du
problème vous racontez ce moment où la
principal et son fameux collègue inquiet
de ne pas le voir inquiet qui qu'il a
fait une connerie hein vont chez lui et
qu' le trouve en train d'aller jouer au
tennis lui-même surpris de les voir
débarquer oui alors il se trouve que le
vendredi donc qui suit la première le
premier vendredi puisque le second ce
sera le jour de son assassinat ce
premier vendredi le référent laïcité va
débarquer vous savez quand il y a un
problème une atteinte à la laïcité les
procédures qui ont été mises en place
par Jean-Michel Blanquer prévoit de
signaler un fait d'établissement et donc
de dépêcher sur place un référent de la
laïcité alors bon on peut être frappé
par le côté très savant de ce référent
de la laïcité qui donne des leçons qui c
qui cite Jul ferry
abondamment et puis qui demande tout de
suite aussi à à à à Samuel paatti de ne
surtout rien faire de ne surtout plus se
mêler de son affaire finalement ce qui
est assez oui parce que là pardon on est
surtout frappé quand vous racontez le
récit par le fait qu'en fait il fait une
leçon de de laïcité à Samuel Patti en
lui disant qu'il a rien compris à la
laïcité absolument et et et et donc il
lui demande de se tenir à l'écart de
tout cela de ne surtout pas venir parler
au au parents d'élèves et donc Samuel
pati j'imagine assez agacé par cette
situation mais là je veux pas le faire
parler paix à son âme et et va euh bah
va quitter l'établissement et va rentrer
chez lui il sait qu'il a une partie de
tennis à disputer et et ça va lui
changer les les les idées mais la mais
la proviseur se rend compte au bout d'un
moment qu'il n'est plus là et elle a
immédiatement ce qui veut dire qu'elle
sait finalement qu'il est menacé c'est
qu'elle va être un peu en stress et elle
va demander à un de ses collègues de
l'accompagner et d'aller voir où estce
qu'il est et et ils vont le retrouver
près de chez lui sortant avec son sac de
sport il vient de disputer une partie de
tennis il dit que tout va bien mais on
voit bien que là la professe que la
principale pardon elle sent elle sait
que Samuel Patti est menacé et à partir
de ce moment-là on voit bien que
l'engrenage de toute façon est lancé sur
les réseaux sociaux les islamistes sont
partage les vidéos du père de famille
mais c'est ça aussi parce que le père de
famille c'est pas n'importe qui entre
guillemets c'est c'est pas père de
famille lambda ça vous le racontez oui
Brahim schnina le père de famille est
est quelqu'un qui est c'est un excité
c'est quelqu'un qui fait du ramdame
régulièrement j'en ai appris d'ailleurs
beaucoup à son sujet depuis cette
enquête puisqu'il y a des langues qui se
sont déliées mais il est il est allé à
l'école aussi avec une bien troublante
personnalité qui est monsieur sefriwi
sefriwi qui a petit in dente créer
participer à la création du collectif
pour le Cher Yassine donc qui est la
délégation du Hamas en France donc ce
n'est pas rien et et donc ces deux
hommes ont fait des vidéos fait des
vidéos qui sont partagées sur les
réseaux sociaux et à partir du moment où
la mosquée de pentin qui est une mosquée
connue pour des prises de position très
rigoristes partage les vidéos de ses de
ses parents d'élèves et bien d'un seul
coup c'est des centaines de milliers de
personnes il y a 100000 followers à qui
qui poursuivre le le compte Facebook de
la mosquée de pentin donc si vous voulez
où le nome pardon sur les réseaux
sociaux le nom de Samuel Patti son
adresse son collège exactement comme
bravo et tout ça est partagé et d'un
seul coup évidemment c'est une c'est une
quantité de personnes
absolument insurveillable entre
guillemets qui qui sont sensibilisé à ce
qui vient de se passer au collège du
boisô et parmi ces personnes il y a un
certain abdouah kzorov qui habite à
Évreux donc c'est pas la porte à côté
qui va être sensibilisé et qui va
prendre contact avec le père de famille
et et dont vous dites c'est c'est c'est
l'assassin samelpatti don dont vous
dites que l'enquête a prouvé qu'il n'y a
eu jamais aucun contact il ne le
connaissait pas il n'y avait jamais
aucune relation des contacts mais qui
sont des alors il av aucune relation
entrex aucune relation entre Samuel
paaty et son assassin ils ne se sont
jamais vu jamais croisé il n'y aura que
des contacts téléphoniques avec le père
de famille qui euh euh derrière des
politesses euh on va dire religieuses va
lui partager que ce ce tout ça ne
restera pas impuni et et donc ce ce ce
ce tueur si on entend bien ce que veut
dire le ministre de l'Intérieur de
l'époque gerérald narmanin et on ne
pouvait pas prévoir on ne pouvait pas
prévoir ce que l'on pouvait prévoir en
revanche c'est que Samuel pati était
menacé on ne pouvait pas savoir celui
qui allait émerger qui aura été signalé
plusieurs fois sur le réseau phos comme
étant un dangereux activistes comme
étant comme proférant la haine la haine
des de de des homosexuels la haine des
femmes enfin c'est c'est un personnage
abjecte ce ce tueur ce tetchenen de 19
ans mais si on ne pouvait pas pr savoir
que c'était lui qui allait être la main
armée du crime en revanche on peut
prévoir que Samuel pay est menacé et là
il y a une faille c'est que normalement
vous avez plusieurs possibilités pour
protéger un professeur ou une
personnalité menacée vous pouvez lui
mettre une protection particulière mais
vous pouvez aussi faire des chose
extrêmement simple il suffisait d'un
coup de fil de la DGSI d'un agent de la
DGSI pour dire à Samuel Patti n'allez
plus en cours et on est à quelques jours
des vacances de la tousin profitez-en
pour aller chez vos parents ou ou chez
des amis ne venez plus à l'école on
n'est pas sûr de pouvoir assurer votre
sécurité on voit dans votre Liv c'est
aussi la faillite la faillite des
renseignements on voit là la faillite
totale des renseignements qui ne voit
pas les les signalement de sur la
plateforme Faros de Abdou KZ ministère
de l'Intérieur chargé de surveiller les
réseaux sociau de signaler les
mess chargé de surveiller les réseaux
sociaux cette plateforme est totalement
débordé et il se trouve que tous les
signalements il y en a eu 14 je crois
dont quatre la semaine précédente sur ce
abdouah kzorov et bien rien n'a été
exploité par la DGSI et par ailleurs la
DGSI n'a absolument rien fait pour
protéger Samuel Patti alors que une
simple mesure d'éloignement qui qui est
aussi facile qu'un coup de fil euh
aurait suffi à sauver la peau de Samuel
Patti et et vous racontez justement
c'est le début de votre livre le jour de
de l'assassina que Samuel paatti se
sentant menacé il avait toujours un
marteau dans son sac et là ça en est
presque émouvant de se dire qu'il se
sentait tellement seul qui s'est
retrouvé avec un outil finalement de
bricolage pens c'est poignant d'Ant que
j'ai appris depuis que ce petit marteau
qui est un marteau insignifiant de
bricolage et bien lui avait été offert
par son père son père lui avait procuré
ce petit mar quand il était étudiant
pour bricoler dans sa chambre poser un
cadre un poster ou je ne sais quoi et et
il se trouve que Samuel pti qui se sait
menacer il suffit de regarder les
réseaux sociaux pour voir les
commentaires aineux qui se compent par
dizaines pour savoir donc il est menacé
d'ailleurs il le dit il l'écrit à ses
collèguue nous produisons le mail le
contenu du mail qu'il adresse à tous en
disant qu'il est menacé par des
islamistes locaux et bien il n'a plus
lui comme ressource comme c'est pas du
tout le genre à aller s'armer ou acheter
un couteau ou est il prend ce petit
marteau en se disant que peut-être il en
aura besoin si jamais d'aventure on
venait à à menacer sa vie et il le met
dans son sac à dos il ne le ver il ne
pourra évidemment pas l'utiliser il sera
frappé de dos par son criminel alors
votre livre on l'a dit hein c'est ça
raconte beaucoup de faillite la faillite
des renseignements généraux la lâcheté
des de certains collègues de Samuel pati
et de sa hiérarchie et peut-être aussi
les failles béantes de l'éducation
nationale parce que vous dites
Jean-Michel Blanquer qui était le
ministre d'éducation nationale à
l'époque il a entendu parler de Samuel
Patti uniquement le jour de mort alors
que des signalements avaient été faits
oui oui oui euh il y a beaucoup de
signalements qui ont été faits la
plupart sont monter au niveau de
l'Académie mais on sait très bien que
ces signalements de niveau 3 et bien ils
sont aussi ils remontent aussi au
ministère et le problème c'est que
malheureusement Jean-Michel blankerer
qui est pourtant un des ministres qui a
voulu réaffirmer les valeurs de la
République c'est un ministre volontaire
c'est quelqu'un qui a conscience des
atteintes à de à la laïcité à
l'intérieur des enceintes de l'école et
bien malgré tout il a mis en place des
procédures qui sont lourdes et qui
remontent tellement de signalements
qu'ils ne sont pas traités et il m'a il
m'a dit les yeux dans les yeux que oui
Samuel Patil n'en avait entendu parler
que le jour de son assassinat et
qu'auparavant je lui faisais remarquer
qu'il y avait une trentaine ou une
quarantaine une cinquantaine de pas de
signalements sur laaffire pati mais
qu'il y avait des signalements régulier
à son ministère et donc ça faisait en
partie et il m'a dit mais vous vous
rendez compte oui peut-être mais enfin
30 30 à 40 signalements comme ça on peut
pas tout traiter et bien alors à quoi
sert de faire des procédures de
signalement s'ils ne sont pas traités
derrière est-ce que c'est juste pour
avoir des déclenchements de signaux qui
vous savez c'est comme quelqu'un qui a
qui installe dans sa voiture une alarme
on vient fracturer son alarme ça sonne
mais bon au bout d'un moment il se rend
compte que c'est simplement il ça se ça
se déclenche à tout bout de champ donc
finalement il ne tient plus compte de
l'alarme donc c'est exactement ça ce qui
se passe et et malheureusement le
l'éducation nationale n'a pas non plus
prend le prix les mesur nécessaire et
utile votre livre c'est aussi le le
récit et même une alerte j'allais dire
sur l'entrrisme de l'islamisme dans les
école euh parce que vous le dites très
bien les écoles c'est la jeunesse c'est
au moment où se forment les esprits et
c'est le meilleur vecteur pour l' vous
savez c'est très documenté les services
de renseignement savent que l'islam
politique considère que c'est dans
l'enceinte de l'école qu'il faut aussi
porter le combat un combat d'idée un
combat finalement pour faire accepter
euh les tenues euh pour faire accepter
euh et pour faire pour faire reculer un
certain nombre d'enseignements je pense
à l'enseignement de la choix euh donc
tout ça est documenté on sait que les
Frères musulmans considèrent que c'est
le lieu de la fabrication des jeunes
esprits qui est essentiel et et c'est là
qu'il faut porter l'effort donc à partir
de ce moment-là on doit bien se rendre
compte et faire en sorte de protéger ce
qui est une enceinte sacrée qui est
celle des établissements scolaires
est-ce que le combat il n'est pas a déjà
perdu on le voit le jour de l'hommage à
Samuel Patier Emmanuel Macron il avait
promis que le collège porterait son nom
c'est toujours pas le cas est-ce que
pour vous c'est le signe que ce combat
contre l'islamisme notamment à l'école
il est perdu aujourd'hui moi je dis que
tant qui vous savez vous connaissez
l'histoire tragique du du Titanic et
vous savez que dans le Titanic il y
avait un il y avait un aquarium et dans
cet aquarium il y avait un Homar et le
il y a eu une bonne nouvelle c'est que
le Homar a pu sortir de vous voyez ce
que je veux dire il y a toujours une
parcelle une lueur des espoir il faut
jamais renoncer à un combat quand on est
fort de ses valeurs je pense qu'il faut
surtout pas se dire c'est trop tard il y
a plus rien à faire moi je m'écrase j'ai
fait ce livre moi aussi pour tous les
professeurs étant fils comme je vous le
rappelais étant fils de prof et cetera
mais il se trouve que je crois que le
plus détestable dans cette affaire c'est
qu'à l'issue de cette affaire Samuel pti
et bien un professeur sur deux dit dans
le sondage qu'il souhaite quitter son
job est-ce que vous connaissez un autre
métier qui est aussi euh comment
dirais-je déprimé aujourd'hui que
celui-ci un professeur sur deux a envie
de quitter sa fonction et pas parce que
c'est mal payé ça pourrait être une
motivation c'est aussi parce qu'ils ne
se sentent plus bien plus protégés plus
assez encadrés plus porté par leur
ministère et cetera donc il y a un
chantier énorme qui attend Gabriel Atal
qui a l'air lui pour le coup un peu plus
concerné que son prédécesseur par les
atteintes à la laïcité dans les
enceintes dans les enceintes scolaires
donc je dis pas c'est fichu je fais
partie de ceux qui pensent que une forme
euh comment dirais-je de de de volonté
politique est absolument essentielle
mais une fois qu'on a manifesté cette
volonté politique il faut agir en ce
sens et et et on verra bien ce que ce
qui se passera dans les prochains mois
merci Stéphane Simon évidemment j'invite
tout le monde à lire votre livre les
derniers jours de Samuel pati c'est à la
fois galasson évidemment mais riche en
enseignement merci d'avoir été notre
invité je remonte votre livre he les
derniers jours de Samuel pti enquête sur
une tragédie qui aurait dû être évité
ces aux éditions plomb on va le voir
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
on passe au club des territoires